okay okay Rick Wilson do you think Trump
will face a Republican challenger in
2020 great question
no nope why is it I think that all these
guys will look at it and they will watch
the Horde out there and they will have
Fox in Breitbart nuking them 24/7 and
they will and every single one of them
will walk away from it all right nobody
serious at this point what does the
panel think about the Trump
administration's plan to replace their
travel ban with more specific
restrictions I don't know what that
means what are the more specific do you
know the countries will Trump rip up the
Iran deal and what happened this is you
know this thing where he goes you know
I've made my decision but I'm not
telling you yet until next week right
February may in November that's tell me
well yes but that would be such a
horrible thing if he ripped up the array
I mean it's bad enough the Paris thing
but that wasn't even a binding that was
you know a little curious it's also not
gonna help with negotiating with north
if we lose our credibility that we can
actually abide by any diplomatic
agreement that is telling kim yo-jong
don't bother signing a deal with me
because it'll have no but it was it's
interesting is that he's sort of
chickening out one doing it by the way
one of the things that's striking to me
is how little he has gotten done in his
speech that he was somebody all that
he's done and what's striking at how
little he has gotten done and that has
not affected his people I've decided his
role and it's what his people wanted to
be he is the insulter in chief he is
very good at insulting everybody that
his people think have mistreated them
and after he's done that they don't need
a thing but very little exchange in the
world with Korea with Iran with
Middle East and I think with Iran he's
gonna maybe send it to Congress but in
the end he's not gonna isn't always
amazing how even the people he's
insulted seem to forget about it in a
couple of days Meryl Streep still pissed
off yeah Chuck Schumer is not a
Republican and he's called him a
lightweight and insulted him up and down
and out Chuck a couple days ago was a
smart transacts politician and and he
knows that he can roll Trump by going in
the office if you really are a
magnificent golden idol I think what
they come out of that Trump Schumer
Pelosi deal is very good news for the
Democrats in 2018 in the house the
Republicans were counting on demonizing
Nancy policy John Asif was doing well
and they went after Pelosi it's gonna be
very hard for Republicans now to say oh
you you're gonna go to Washington and
vote with Nancy Pelosi yeah and the
answer is yeah like Donald Trump did he
has legitimacy that wanted their weapon
and one reason why jackoff lost that
race was because he didn't defend Nancy
Pelosi which is the disease of you and
me that's over I understand that but I
do think the more important point is it
next time he's not gonna even be able to
use that weapon he's not gonna be able
to attack Nate they're not gonna be able
to attack no they won't
oh no this TV thing because I for
example cannot watch Fox and I have many
many Democratic friends who watch it to
learn and to understand what the other
side's there and I can't do it and the
reverse is that people are never going
to watch they'll see the edge of Trump
being nice to Nancy Pelosi and I believe
this will substantially diminish the
ability of a Republican candidate to
benefit from from discrediting a
Democrat by associating with Katherine
what can we expect from a Republican tax
reform plan
Oh aren't you glad you got that yeah
okay then give it to it well first of
all it's not gonna be tax reform it's
gonna be tax cuts and there's a big
difference one is you know about closing
loopholes and and making sure that it's
paid for and the other one is just about
a big giveaway to the rich and if
anything that's what we'll see the
problem is that they're all of these
once again my point that Trump is not
that different but it's not as easy as
just cutting taxes across the board
because there are a lot of these like
bells and whistles in how the Senate
works that makes it actually very
difficult to not have a paid for tax cut
so that's really gonna be the challenge
is fitting the puzzle pieces together
and every single thing you would need to
do to pay for it is really unpopular
right I mean to take away the mortgage
deduction is that ever gonna happen in
America or state local or the or things
like the border adjustment tax which
nobody even remembers anymore but that
was supposed to be a big windfall there
were a lot of things that were supposed
to help pay for this including actually
repealing Obamacare part of the reason
why they've been so gung-ho about
repealing Obamacare is because that
includes tax increases in it and if you
bundle all of that with the Obamacare
repeal rather than into the separate
bill
Obamacare is not putting us into the red
no no actually making a little money
because you know it was a redistribution
of income when they accused him of that
he should have said yeah [ __ ] yeah
exactly that's exactly what we're doing
before taking money
from people who will never miss it and
giving it to poor people who desperately
need it healthcare right Bob what were
your thoughts on Jamil Hill the ESPN
host who criticized Trump on Twitter
right she called him a white supremacist
yeah yeah I don't know Jamel Hill I hear
good things about her but my thought is
this she has a program every night on
ESPN she has a platform right what she
did was in elegant weather you more or
less agree with it or not it's an
elegant it's not a good way to make a
point you know being on Twitter and
going back and forth with people on
Twitter you know long before it was ever
invented George Bernard Shaw said do not
wrestle with a pig you get dirty and the
pig enjoys it if you're a boldface name
if you're a boldface name why do you
want to be engaged with some dope on on
Twitter because he said something and
you come back at him and back and forth
back and forth she should go on her own
he's the president and he know she
wasn't responding to him was she called
him a white supremist and but she should
if she wants to make her point she
should go on her own program and make a
fulsome textures at one point he said
her program is I don't agree with that
but first of all her program is on ESPN
it's a sports show
yeah it would be completely out of place
for her to you know it's not right not
really the guards gonna come back next
year oh and our next topic is what met
reference yeah
is Trump a white supremacist that but
but Twitter is the appropriate that
she's a human being she's a citizen why
can't she say her I just hate this idea
that nobody can say anything without
somebody wanting them to go away because
they don't know I'm with you all super
set on that I just think that she could
have chosen a better way to make her
point and that way is available to her
accusing someone of treating Trump in
elegantly
it's like saying and someone that's
silly about the Three Stooges
[Laughter]
and by the way I always thought Shemp
never got it Shanna's very to your
cousin how it was man how the cousin
babe Frank with shemp's wife my father's
cousin
you see we learned something every day
what a team my second cousin was WK is
that true
no I'm bragging wouldn't I have set a
bigger name my second cousin was Jolson
I mean I would've Arnie what are you
making from efforts and bipartisanship
Oh with Chuck and Nancy what do you
think about that actually I think it
reflects in fact dad he doesn't mind if
the Democrats take over and he might
even like that I believe this is a man
who cares only about himself and his ego
accomplishments without substance I mean
there's the thing about him is that he
talks about it conscious and again on
the health care bill every version of
the health care bill has been different
than every other version
there was no consistency to any program
on health care it's just we got to beat
those guys I think he's getting
frustrated that he's getting some
tarnish because of the Republicans
inability to deliver and I think what
he's done with Chuck and Nancy I think
helps the Democrats and I think he
doesn't mind that I could see in
searching parties and his followers go I
think right exactly
there's one buddy right he doesn't want
to be blamed for the Republicans and I
think but the other thing is this I tell
you what I believe about the guy he's
among other things
lazy yeah he's not just and here's the
deal agreeing with humor and Pelosi
meant no hassle about the debt limit
being raised no hassle birthright he can
go off for a couple weeks
it means he doesn't have to spend his
Christmas with all that I did over there
I think he was just sick of talking
about yeah but well
wanted to get it done but if someone did
say to him you're gonna help the
Democrats win I think he answered the
back of his mind well I wouldn't be so
[ __ ] then I'll run in 2020 as the
victim of all these bad people and I
don't think he's from this planet he
never sleeps never sleep he only eats
hamburgers well-done right steak and he
never ever gets a cold he's never seen
during the debates he had like that
really heavy breathing so maybe he's
just like in a steady funny you know he
feels stress yeah I know this is I'm a
I'm a stress eater I gained weight in
tough campaigns the man is getting
fatter and fatter I mean look he claimed
that one superlative which he's entitled
a claim that he has left out he is the
fattest president since William Howe
would tell you yes I have two they now
have to butter the doorframes of the
Oval
goodnight I'm not making that up I think
it's I think his his biggest problem is
that unlike his life in New York he
can't get laid I think when he lived in
New York you know he had he had a sex
life that he enjoyed not with milani of
course that's the wife what do you but
you know he left in the morning and
Milani I'll be home at nine o'clock okay
Annie we know he has apartment C his
houses he could have gone anywhere with
anybody hookers Russians peeing whatever
the [ __ ] were children have now and you
can't do that in the White House I think
that more than anything else you do that
no I know yeah I get your book okay
Clinton proved that that was very he
didn't get away with it in the White
House and he had to do it with the trunk
ichika brought in the mail that's the
only the one you know about
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's true I think that's I think
that's Trump's biggest frustration but
we'll talk about that again another
night thank you very much
[Applause]